[Music]
the short story
the word of unbinding is one of ursula k
leguin's
very first forays into her narrative
universe of earthsea and
already in this story we see some of the
really key elements at play
i want to begin by just reading some of
the first lines of the first
paragraphs to give you a sense
where was he the floor was hard and
slimy the air black and stinking
and that was all there was except a
headache lying
flat on the clammy floor fest and moaned
and then
said staff when his alder woods wizard
staff did not come to his hand he knew
he was in peril
he sat up and not having his staff with
which to make a proper light he struck a
spark
between finger and thumb uttering a
certain word a blue will of the wisp
sprang from the spark and rolled feebly
through the air sputtering
a little bit later he must have been
overspelled from behind by surprise for
the last memory
he had was of walking through his own
woods
at evening talking with the trees lately
in these lone years in the middle of his
life he'd been burdened with a sense of
waste
of unspent strength so needing to learn
patience he'd left the villages
and go on to converse with trees
especially oaks chestnuts on the great
alders
whose roots are in profound
communication with
running water a little bit later
in this so who had spellbound him and
shut him in this wreaking well
who he demanded of the walls and slowly
a name
gathered on them and ran down to them
like a thick black drop
sweated out from pores of stone and
spores of fungus
vole so already in these
first two paragraphs of this short story
were seeing a lot of key themes being
put into play
festen is a wizard vol we don't quite
know about him yet although we find out
in the next paragraphs a good bit um
is also going to be a wizard
there are some other key themes
connected with
nature festen goes and talks with the
trees and
it's not just a communication of human
being
with nature nature itself is a body
of communicative action and engagement
the alders
communicate with other things through
their roots so this is very typically
liguinian we could say magic
is going to play a central role and
there are
structures and rules to it
classifications that we can talk about
at the same time there are
ways in which magic can be used or
misused and there is a connection to the
wider world as well this is really
in many respects a story of conflict
there is a conflict between the two
main characters and a protagonist and an
antagonist a conflict that is going to
involve
magic itself as a tool
in a certain respect going beyond mere
instrumentality though
thinking trying to outsmart each other
that's a central
uh aspect of this as well and then we
could say
commitment festen is going to commit to
something
by the very end that will allow him
to have the victory even though he
appears to be the vanquished one
so let's talk about these these two
characters we have feston we've already
got to know him a little bit we know
that he's middle aged we know that he
feels like maybe some of his power has
been wasted and so he
is learning patience by strolling around
and talking with the trees
he's described both as a wizard and as a
warlock as a young warlock and a
paragraph a little bit later on
and we find him here in this stinking
well in a trap in a prison cell
beneath the ground so has he been taken
from his island home earth sea by the
way
is a number of islands within a much
larger
body of water so let's let's
look a little bit further on as a young
warlock intent on his trading he had not
paid much attention to talk about
this full person i can protect this
island he'd thought knowing his untried
power
and he'd return to his oaks and alders
the sound of wind in their leaves the
rhythm of growth in their round trunks
and limbs and twigs
the taste of sunlight on leaves or dark
ground water around
roots so we we find out that he's
connected with
the natural world as part of what it
means to be
a wizard or warlock so he sees
nature in a way that other human beings
might get glimpses of but don't
necessarily get and it's part of
le guin's exquisite storytelling that
she's helping us to enter
into this world that obviously we not
wizards not
warlocks let alone mages um
can share with with us what about this
this other person
full the fell so there is an entire
description well not a description of
the person
as such but a description let's call it
of the function or of the exercise of
his power
festen had first had heard first long
ago of foal the fell
who is said to be more than wizard yet
less than man
who passed from island to island of the
outer
reach these are the islands that are on
the
the periphery of earth sea undoing the
works of the ancients
enslaving men cutting forests and
spoiling fields
and sealing in underground tombs any
wizard
or mage who tried to combat him
refugees from ruined islands told always
the same tale
he came at evening on a dark wind over
the sea his slaves followed in
ships these they had seen none of them
had ever seen
full there were many men and creatures
of evil will among the islands and
festen had not paid much heed to these
tales so it's not as if foal is the only
bad person in the world
this is not a uh everything on the side
of light versus everything on the side
of darkness or good
evil kind of story there is plenty of
evil to go around but full
is in some respect a catalyst a
concentration of evil within
this world and that's a great phrase
more than wizard but less than man
prefiguring
what we're going to see at the very end
of
the story so what does feston do
this is where we get to these conflicts
right
he's going to use magic and here we're
going to see some of the
many servants of full the fell
involved in this particularly trolls
right
and guards people but also the effects
of some of the spells that he's
got set up so feston is going to use
three kinds of magic incidentally right
in the conflict because he also does use
magic to heal himself and he uses magic
to
send the little you know will of the
wisp up there to light the place up
but the magic that's really going to
account for something
is transformation uh what leguin is
going to describe
as the spell of homecoming and then
finally the
word of unbinding so what's
transformations turning into
something different he doesn't just
transform
into animals although he does take the
form
of some animals for example a hawk
he also transforms into a gold ring he
transforms
into a mist he transforms
into an odor of
of cooking meat right and with each of
the transformations he is making an
attempt
by transforming his body by taking out a
new
form which is is a bit dangerous because
you know if you stay in that form too
long you can become the thing as we find
out later
in some of the earthsea novels
taking on that form you accept the
vulnerabilities of it so
he takes on the form of a mist then
there's a hot dry wind
that would destroy the mist that would
destroy him right he takes on the form
of the the hawk to fly out he gets hit
by an arrow which turns out to be
his shoulder as a human being
and with each attempt at transformation
full through his magic or through
his servants has
managed to out-think fessen he's set
things up
in his favor and festan knows that the
odds are against him already he says
listen i'm stuck in this guy's dungeon i
don't have my staff
i'm at half my power and we see
progressively
as he tries and tries and tries things
he is not just
losing time he's losing blood he's
losing energy
so there's a second kind of magic that
he ends up using and in this case
it's not so much about saying the the
proper word or name
instead it's something else that occurs
so he strikes a will of the wisp
right and lit the wreaking air the same
dark mist
he had seen as he flew over hanging his
forest in little towns of his land
it was up to him to protect that land he
could not
attempt direct escape again he was too
weak and tired
trusting his power too much he had lost
his strength so
the transformation exhausted the
resources
that he had shivering with coldy
crouched there letting the fireball
sputter out with the last width of
methane marsh gas the smell brought to
his mind's eye
the marshes stretching from the forest
wall down to the sea
his beloved marches where no men came
wherein
fall the swans flew long and level where
between still pools and rita islands
the quick silent seaward streamlets ran
oh
to be a fish in one of those streams or
better
yet to be farther upstream near the
springs
in the forest in the shadow of the trees
in the clear brown
backwater under an alder's roots resting
hidden
so this is him in the dungeon sort of
thinking about
his land which he knows intimately this
is not something
that somebody who had only seen a
documentary could visualize right
this is by direct experience by
communication
by what we you know when i was a child
called woodcraft
being able to walk the trails and it
could be marsh craft
as well now leguin says
this was a great magic feston had no
more performed it than has any man
who in exile or danger longs for the
earth and waters of his home
seeing and yearning over the door sill
of his house the table where he has
eaten the branches outside the window
of the room where he has slept only in
dreams do any but the great mages
realize this magic of going
home but festen with a cold creeping
out from his marrow into nerves and
veins stood up among between
the black walls gathered his will
together until it's shown like a candle
in the darkness of his flesh
and began to work the great and silent
magic so there is a
deliberative aspect to this but festen
is less drawing upon an art that he has
learned
and more something that is available
there
in nature should we call upon it that
is a correspondence between our our
desire for home
and the actual place and he winds up
being in that home which is not a house
but rather his forest and his water
the walls were gone he was in the earth
rocks and veins of granite for bones
groundwater for blood the roots of
things for nerves so another
transformation has taken place but this
is a transformation
of a different sort like a blind worm he
flowed through the earth westward slowly
darkness before and behind
then all at once coolness flowed along
his back and belly a buoyant unresisting
irresistible caress with his sides he
tasted the water
felt current flowing with lidless eyes
he saw before him the deep brown pool
between the great buttress roots of an
alder he darted forward
silverly into the shadow he'd got free
he was home
and he winds up taking on the shape of a
trout
hiding under the alder roots
but he's found by a servant of foal a
troll
it takes many attempts but they catch
him and he
is put back into the shape of a human
being
and put back into the dungeon so he
the second uh great kind of magic
surpassing that of transformation has
failed and now he's
close to death his ribs have been
cracked by the squeezing
of the troll what is he going to do
here's where he out thinks
full and realizes something
and then decides to undertake a
different kind of
magic he says
why has he not killed me why is he why
does he keep me here alive
why has he never been seen with what
eyes can he be seen on what ground does
he walk
he fears me though i have no strength
left they say that all the wizards and
men in power who he is defeated
live on and see sealed in tombs like
this year after year trying to get free
what if one chose not to live so festen
makes a
choice he whispers the word of unbinding
which is
only spoken once and leguin says this
was not transformation he was not
changed the body the long legs and arms
the clever hands
the eyes that had liked to look on trees
and streams lay unchanged only still
perfectly still and full of cold but the
walls were gone
the vaults built by magic were gone and
the rooms and towers in the forest and
the sea
and the sky of evening they were all
gone and festen went slowly down the far
slope of the hill of being under new
stars
he's now in a different place and we'll
talk about that place in just a moment
but what does this allow him to do
he's able to call out his enemy
feston is now dead he's in the place
of the dead he's realized that foal
himself
has his power by having crossed
from the border of death into
life as you could say a malevolent
spirit
exercising control in the world through
all of these
functions the servants exploiting
destroying imprisoning
but now in the realm of the dead
festen can take him on and he does so he
calls out full by his name
and he forces him to go into the dead
body
that he had left behind and festen
keeps watch on it here's the description
a long way they they went over dry la
lava flows from the great extinct
volcanoes
across spurs of silent hills through
valleys of short black grass
past towns or down their unlit streets
between houses through whose windows no
face
looked there was no change here no day
would come
feston drove the other before until they
reached a place where once a river had
run
and a dead body lay that of an old man
naked
flat eyes staring at the stars that are
innocent of death
enter it feston said the full shadow
whimpered
but feston came closer full cowered away
stooped and entered into the open mouth
of his own dead body
at once the corpse vanished
feston is resting there said he must
keep guard until full's body sent back
to his grave
had turned into dust all evil power gone
scattered by the wind and washed seaward
by the rain
he must keep watch over this place where
once death had found a way back into the
other
land and this is the first description
that we have
of what is going to be called the dry
land notice that it has things like
towns
and houses but nothing changes there is
no
wind it is gray and
there is just existence
not life that is where feston goes
sacrificing himself so that he can make
something
valuable something meaningful out of
his inevitable death and to
undo some of the the the evil if not
necessarily the damage
that is done by this malevolent
thing full who had crossed from
death as an old man back into
life to conquer to exploit to cause
fear and dismay among so many others and
this is where the story
comes to a close so a lot of very
interesting
thematics and what are going to become
key ideas of earthsea already being
brought to bear within the fabric of
a very quickly told story
here in the word of unbinding by ursula
k
leguin
you